ladies and gentlemen breaking
post-millennial Arizona GOP chair tried
to bribe Carrie Lake to not run for
Senate leaked audio he told Lake people
were willing to put their money where
their mouth is I mean the audio from
this is ABS absolutely nuts he says
things like very powerful people don't
want you to run quote there are very
powerful people who want to keep you out
he told Lake in a conversation last
March Jeff dwit told her that the people
were willing to put their money where
their mouth is this is about defeating
Trump and I think that's a bad bad thing
for our country she replied these people
are corrupt it's about control after
Lake asked what the powerful people
wanted from her he said they want you to
stay out for two years I'll tell you
what I can offer you dot continued
saying that there were companies that
could quote just put her on the payroll
to keep her out of the senate race in
the state when Lake pushed back against
the idea dwit asked just say is there a
number at which lake cut in say saying I
can be bought that's what it's about
after insisting to Lake that she could
have a bigger voice in politics and to
take the offer of the bribe Lake said
that doing so would be immoral and she
wouldn't be able to look at herself in
the mirror the same dit insisted that
Lake not tell anyone the conversation
happened now it's a 10-minute recording
I don't want to play everything but I I
do want to play the end part where he
fears assassination but I also want to
point out in it he mentions you can be a
big personality you could be a big voice
it is about defeating Donald Trump
that's why they want her out for two
years they want Trump to lose after that
then you can do whatever you want let me
play the last portion of this and you
can hear it for yourself this stuff's
wild and okay let me refresh because x
video always does that and let's try
again what about dis santis getting
santis
in getting dis santis is getting Trump
it's not you're reading too deep into it
well let's see what happens maybe my
case will go through maybe they'll do
the right
thing I doubt I hope so I do too that's
my first goal yeah but they can't have
me in the governor's office cuz then
we're going to root out some of this
corruption but again it's like you know
what it is the people don't get to
choose their elected officials unless
they're pre-approved by the
swamp and the swamp doesn't pre-approve
of me you need a strong party to help
you I think you should go public with it
and say hey these people don't want to
they don't want then I turn my key in my
car and
I I like then I turn my key in my car
and it
goes very powerful people sent this man
to bribe Carrie Lake into dropping out
because they want their pre-approved
candidates to be put in place and they
were going to pay her off so that she
would stop trying and this man says if
he goes public they will kill him it
with a Car Bomb now maybe he doesn't
literally mean Car Bomb but he no no no
no no no then I turned my key in my car
and I think the implication is very very
obvious who are these powerful
people yeah I mean I'm going to be
honest with you guys we've been swatted
several times I know there are crazy
people out there people ask me if I'm
ever concerned about my safety and I
always say I'm less concerned with
antifa than I am with the crazy man who
thinks I broke into his house to steal
all of his spoons crazy people see you
and they say crazy
things I don't know anyone that I fear
in the immediate would try to kill me
and I don't I I mean I don't know if
anyone else here or anyone's been on the
show uh uh would would would in the
immediate say someone will kill me if I
do a thing you know what I mean yeah
this is a guy who's saying if I take
this action they will kill me he knows
who they are he knows the powerful
people that have put him up to this he
knows them someone sent him there and he
thinks if I cross them they'll kill me
who's he working
with well it's crazy you know it's
fascinating because we hear about you
know the Deep State the swamp all these
things we hear about these kind of
conversations taking place in politics
and then here we are we get a a firstand
you know listen to this and so it's one
thing to hear about it I think it's
totally different when you actually
listen to the video and you hear that it
kind of put it in a new context for me
and I'm sure many others out there as
well yeah I mean I think it's only
breeding more distrust in the system
that's already there and I think in some
ways the political theater has gotten so
dramatic that people really equated to
um what was that show that had Frank on
it and uh the and like all these DC sort
of s not like drum house CS thank you
they think anything could happen but
then things like this come out and they
say oh it's all real it's all real uh
and they I think that's ultimately plays
into sort of this Elite group's uh Power
right they want you to be scared and
nobody ever came here and offered me a
bunch of money for any of this stuff
what's going on if this is what's going
on then we have a situation uh in
American politics that is a real problem
this is what we see in Russia we see
this kind of thing in Ukraine we see
this kind of thing where people are just
taken out you never hear from them again
in China if we have a situation where we
have itical um operatives operating
behind the scenes to take people out if
they do a misstep then um I I think most
Americans would not be prepared for that
reality it sounds like Carrie Lake
recorded this because of the uh volume
of her voice and the volume of Jeff's
voice I'm wondering why it is it took
this long for it to get released you
know maybe she just now felt comfortable
doing it I don't know but it's it's it's
crazy too cuz this is Carrie Lake this
isn't some no-name politician so the
fact that they felt comfortable enough
to go to someone like Carrie Lake and
have that conversation what are they
doing to other people that's just coming
in in desperate enough yeah desperate
enough that's that's a good point that's
why I was saying in the intro to the
show tonight Civil War oh I'm you you
you better be careful because I'm
goingon to say that a lot tonight with
what's going
on they're so panicked and desperate
over what Carri Lake
represents she is America first she is
like she is like Trump and they're
probably thinking we nip this in the bud
now because if she actually advances
politically in this country we are
dealing with Trump once again this time
I'm I'll be completely honest K lake is
a bit more
U what's the right word orthodox I mean
little more poised maybe poised is maybe
the right word Trump is a is a Brash
celebrity character and they find way
ways to use that to make him look bad
but Carrie lake has Decades of
Television experience and she comes off
like top tier political you know uh uh
highlevel like poised I suppose is
probably the best way to put it that is
something they will have they will
struggle with if she is running for
higher office if she is succeeding if
she's in the
Senate they're not going to be able to
stop her Trump trump gives them some
ammunition sometimes and they're going
as dirty as possible possible right now
we know what comes next for K Lake
because in conspiracy World it goes like
this the first thing they do is they ask
you to play ball hey you know we we
really like what you're doing why don't
you come work with us and then you say
no I'm not interested I don't like what
you do then they offer you money okay uh
hey I got this really great opportunity
why don't you take this job in this
other place when you refuse the money
you the next step is the threats the
next thing that happens is maybe there's
a car accident you know family member
has an unfortunate turn and uh we would
hate for that to happen in the
conspiracy world that typically it goes
with recruitment failure bribery failure
threats of violence and assassination
and we've talked about that book was a
confessions of an economic Hitman where
he talks about on the larger scale
basically go to Country you say you are
now part of our machine and our Empire
and if they say no then you offer a
bunch of money and say we'll give you
all these things they say no then you
stay jaku and remove them from power and
install someone who will do what you
want them to do it's like that M python
sketch when he's like when they're like
that it's a nice country you've got here
it' be a shame something happened to it
yeah yeah so I can only imagine with the
release of this audio and the man being
recorded saying effectively they will
kill him Carrie Lake man she needs she
she got to hire some security for her
family they weren't scared of her before
I'm sure they are now cuz I mean she
says in the audio like you're going to
have to kill me not going to buy me
you're not going to pay me off and so
she stood up to this and so I think if
they weren't scared of her before they
probably definitely are now I Fe they
they will I mean look the the the the
sheer desperation we are seeing from the
political Elites in this country is not
Beyond any of that right now
look the it is allegedly a conspiracy
theory that Epstein killed himself what
I mean is the mainstream media reports
that not a single real person in this
country believes abste killed himself
no and that interview with his brother
was really pretty shocking the the the
the the best line ever came from Chris
reun YouTube personality after it
happened he said he got into an Uber and
the first thing that happens the driver
turns around and goes yo that guy didn't
kill himself nobody believes it Epstein
himself in his story was a conspiracy
theory now we know now it's a fact gilan
Maxwell's in jail proven and they still
haven't released The Client List now
that we're starting to see beyond the
curtain that these things are happening
now that we actually got leaked audio of
someone trying to bribe Carrie Lake I
will say right
now I'm just going to goad and assume
all the rest of it true the funny thing
is people have been saying for some time
like two years now Conspiracy Theory
what is Luke's got a shirt conspiracy
theories are just spoiler alerts right
six months six months it's true it
happened with all of them and it
happened in such quick succession you
know it was like getting Whiplash
everything that we were told was true
was a complete lie and now we see you
know you'll see a lot of conversations
bubbling up about the way that history
has been taught and we're suddenly
realizing oh they taught us X Y and Z
about our national history and if you
dig into it it turns out those things
weren't true either I had a professor in
grad school who went through um you know
a whole bunch of stuff he was like a a
Cuban Refugee as a child and he was
brought to Florida and all this stuff
and when things would happen and we'd
talk about history he'd be like listen
that's not how it happened that's not
how it happened at all and he'd start
explaining what it looked like you know
from his perspective having having lived
through it but we're seeing that all
over the place and it's just it's just
compounding it's hard to have any idea
um where to put your front that's going
to be solid ground and I think it's
changing forms too instead of it just
being oh well this is how I was taught
this in high school I mean I remember
being taught stuff and being like this
obvious has bias to it but now it's also
sort of these uh historically based
miniseries that net puts out and they're
actually slightly inaccurate but that's
where a lot of people are learning kind
of the gist of what happened or they
think the gist of what happened during
various points of time uh It ultimately
becomes uh plausible deniability for
anyone in the media who gets to be like
oh well we took some uh creative
Liberties here but you know we don't
have a strong enough and unbiased
education system to say here here is
what you need to know and you can watch
this and deern where they are taking
sort of a political leap and where this
is actually what happened the entire
concept of deconstruction that started
in philosophy has now just hit reality
and we're deconstructing everything
every day well and to your point about
everything kind of speeding up I feel
like they never expected president Trump
to win in 2016 it kind of threw a wrench
in their globalist agenda and their
crying the next day like literally
sobbing and since that since then
everything has kind of just been in
overdrive speeding everything up and I
really think the left is overplayed
their hand with a lot of this though I
mean you know back to you know the the
the lockdowns and the mandates and all
that and what we saw from that where
parents were at home listening to what
was going on inside the classrooms and
all these other things and so I feel
like they almost they overplayed their
hand a lot of people have woken up to
this I mean if you go back seven eight
years not even 10 I mean seven eight
years and tell everybody what took place
over the last few years they would say
you're crazy there's no way that's going
to happen yeah and here we are living in
it yeah I mean but you don't remember
people crying right because you're from
West Virginia that's right which had I
mean there really are states and cities
that had completely different
experiences uh Trump coming to office
was something that a lot of people
celebrated very intensely but you know
you were what in Brook I was actually it
was it was pretty crazy my friends were
sobbing and um I didn't vote for Trump
but I wasn't sobbing I was like oh now
we have a different president and I'm
going to support the president because
I'm an American that's what I do thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time